now it's recording thank you see Malcolm
you say it's not that much of a
difference don't look as youthful as you
usually do
Tamara to something quit it's true you
look like you were 12 when you started
there
yeah so different to how she looks now
now I said you did oh I did we don't
hire 12 year olds we say that cuz she
makes those same jokes
she actually cannot be here today and
one no she will she's gonna be here
later though she has a shoot that was
supposed to be like Wednesday or
Thursday and then they call up and it's
like it's gonna be Tuesday and she's
like shit because it was like some sort
of big chachi and so it is yet but I
think it's allied she just want to sleep
it's porn yeah she said it paid well but
no so pretty much she's gonna show up
later and since
Lando's scene is like because he's gonna
play OD he's gonna be in it like 9:00
p.m. because that's when he gets off so
it's gonna be like oh really really late
night so I told out it's just like if
there's ever a day to come in like
really late not know when you're gonna
come here like this was the day cuz but
only this day you do it again you're
fine and then what we're gonna do here
is that Malcolm's gonna place or the
wise humble cute old black guy that's in
a lot coming brothers movies yeah we can
make a TRO fat of it so we're trying to
make it look old here but here's the
thing we were also gonna do we had a
sketch with him as Obama so we're just
gonna kind of leave the similar makeup
on maybe take a little bit off but this
ain't Obama's hair okay Obama does not
have this hair how awesome though if
Obama rocks that hair yeah so
you superseded be like you know what I'm
a lame-duck president I do what I want
so we're gonna try and like sprays hair
you know white and see a weekend game
we're gonna see if he looks at all like
Obama when this is done if not I'm just
gonna chase the job cuz the joke in it
is that there's a scene cuz you pointed
this out Rob like the bad guy in the
movies coming in and he has like he
comes into this room and there's this
big President of the United States seal
I remember I was just like what the hell
is that about
there's no reason it's literally just
sitting there in the middle of the door
I'm like this makes no sense so angry
because that required us to rewind the
film and this is not a film you want for
one no no but I was like I I apologize
for that but I had to know I'm like no I
did see that there was no connection at
all so we're just like is this something
that Obama's behind so we're gonna have
him like behind a desk saying you know
just now I know our deals have been
controversial but I'm sorry I need these
electric collars and whatever you know
when we have him stick to the Obama
assistants and I'm just explaining the
scene and ability shocks his dog or
something like with the collar you know
that impression wasn't even good enough
to be racist it was it bad enough to be
racist that ended was that like we mask
the black guy he would know Malcolm on a
scale of one to Hulk Hogan how racist
was that that's impressive
I'm not sure I want to show up to any of
your dinner parties someone did an
amazing Photoshop
Hulk Hogan's face on whoo that's like
that's like something out of a nightmare
yeah I don't know what that done well
horribly I would imagine that would look
weird well the fine thing is like cuz
when I heard I heard this was going on
and like oh and people are saying all
because of this audio it's this audio on
YouTube and I'm like I heard I'm like
did sound really like he was talk about
the word but not using it reca no no but
then I saw or I heard about the written
transcripts of like what it really was I
was just like talking to his daughter or
something like that shit I read the
transcript the word out and stuff like
that okay that's not what I heard in
that audio the funny the funny thing is
like this is what it is it's like no
funny thing is after going on this
tirade he's like yeah maybe I'm a little
racist I'm like yeah I've black friends
wait wait if he posted her oh yeah he
was posting there just like you know
yeah you just like takes the C I could
be friends with them I just don't want
my daughter dating them we talk as we're
whitening up Malcolm here we Darth Vader
in him a little bit assist now go tell
your sister to clean a room she's a slob
by the way I found her stash oh it's
carrie fisher's you must have quite a
stack I was gonna say it's gotta be
impressive do we have any good shoes
around here that's one thing I forgot
too bro yeah I had some personally made
for me my shoe tailor my cobbler your
cobbler yeah we have good shoes Doug's
shirt okay son yeah oh look at that
[Music]
which prep to have good shoes listen
there little dusty and news but that's
the kind Garfield would use right Wow
yeah those are those are good shoes get
to me they're good I'm sorry doc I
didn't realize that we stole shiny shoes
oh I'm not gonna clean up after those
does that seem from police squad what's
the word that Jimmy yeah yeah I don't
hire people based on like there there's
a reason there's a reason they fit
perfectly you idiot
they're my shoes yeah yeah yep I mean I
ever you these are way too well-kept
okay well no those are shoes I had for
over a decade and I brought them in as a
prop over well over 15 years ago you
know what we czev our hobbies okay sir
huh I like to tap I'd tap that
wicked nobody saw being wicked and I
still have not seen wicked I've read all
about it though oh my god oh oh now is
every single person who the book is
better and like well yeah cuz you can't
turn a book into a musical
I won't give it away the butler did it
the butler did it what are you playing
this the butler did Lee Lee Lee live
with it Hadley hey Simpson Reverend it's
the same against Italy
I mean diddly I mean diddly diddly do
you know Ned you can switch religions
really they're mostly all the same I
think anybody who's my age of Jim's age
at Doug's ages missed The Simpsons for
at least ten years maybe 15 for some 20
I'd say about 10 years it's like 10
years ago were some of the best episodes
if you say so
Simpsons only the best episodes were in
the 90s to do stuff oh I can
white-balance now no it's white balance
white balance
white balance is my first garage band
white noise store white balance yeah all
right so I mean what I'm looking for
probably as far off as you can probably
get what you did before with the kind of
overexposure a bit from the windows
hello you're overexposed okay but you
know I mean just a hint grain it is not
like you know
super super much mostly gonna be like
hints now that's the one that you're
okay oh man
oh it's cop his name is Fred joke Oh
head it's off by one letter there's an H
in Joe or Joel Joel okay Wow
so that's how they and this is how
actors have agents because they can they
spot those agent other bill fire comes
to mind oh that's true I guess we don't
really need sound on this one so it's no
biggie so I'm just gonna do
scribble-scribble
yeah that's terrible hand acting
that's actually my check for next week
right well I thought I supposed to be
goofy at first and then some colored bar
so there's nothing goofy but is serious
okay we're going to need to turn the
lights
all right just give me a second just to
finish
[Music]
and big beers yes you're some but
Courtney yes this is Spaceballs
reference no I feel like I should be
waiting for like the stormtroopers and
Darth Vader to Buster the Korean
craftsman it's pretty dark this is a
very hot if you want this close-up or do
you want it oh they call me mister call
you a face and just beat it it's a
dog-eat-dog world boy who the hell was
that good mm-hmm
if you're really down like this when you
did your initial you know cutting you
look over your shoulder if you're gonna
come back to this it's not well no no
it's not this is like okay this is did I
chat okay yeah do you want the light
swinging or not rub no I just just leave
it okay ready yep and action
it's a dog-eat-dog world boy who the
hell was backed a trial mama who is that
good yeah okay
what about dog beat dog it's a talk
that's what you said it first I was like
wait it's a dog-eat-dog world boy gonna
help us back this wheelchair smells like
hospital yeah no idea what the fuck all
of our fingerprints are on trying to
find a the rape
yeah like more like flat this yeah very
much Donny
yes five years just and that's weird cuz
it's like he has the really big TC got
this that's that big it's the big guys -
it's just it's hard to do that without
looking like scary but he looks a little
scary so I don't know I'll break it like
some shadow and put it up like the
cheese definitely under the eyes yeah
like that I mean it's it's hard to get
his eyes cuz he just looks like that
yeah yeah man so many people were trying
to give pixels the benefit of the doubt
and no I was ready to until I found out
it was by the Happy Madison people shit
Chris Columbus and this was gonna sort
of be like almost like a quirky return
to like gremlins or something like that
but sign up it's like and then sailors
people are still in charge bitch I was
like from what I'm hearing from like
other people that I've seen that they're
like yeah it's bad but it's not we're 12
or 20 percent bad it's just right I
thought you know they just like slapped
like even over the head is doesn't know
that's that's perfect yeah ray Julia was
jacket now it's junk now we're did yeah
it looks really good on camera
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
so Tamra's here you're like eight hours
late lately half a daily but my thing is
we both have a ton of makeup on us which
one looks better who order at you the
the weird thing is that like you know
how does it look on camera the makeup
because like she has print makeup on
right now like for a could she came from
a man with a magazine shooter yeah it
was like a magazine issue so they cake
the people in makeup and in real life it
looks weird but on print
he looks interesting yeah yeah I was
gonna say that's on camera price really
really good no I mean not as good as
this hilarious but yeah so it's one of
those things where a second purse I'm
like oh you have print makeup on yeah
but that's one of those things where
it's on on the camera
oh yeah it does cuz I saw your photo
ever house like it's that Tamara yeah I
was like ya know it's like it's amazing
what they can give I need to make it can
just like I said real life it's like
let's really but then on my camera it's
like that person looks amazing yeah
that's a great forehead really good
grandpa they hide everything well Sam
there's like a um look Tamara always
knocks me over
yeah well I finished up all my stuff and
then I fell asleep on the couch good
oh yeah oh did you both just leave
together yeah that's cool okay so
there's a few changes in the lines here
you know just ask me cuz I'm a vet are
you there are rules I love a woman
uniform that's so plain but comedic way
desperate Ango before it turns into
creepy stalker ankle sorry Jon I'm
drawing a line in the sand
and apart from millions of readers
demanding me to break character and
finally date you hey I turn to the
camera that really happened look it up I
will keep this running joke going and
you walk off it so you go ahead look at
that well I find this up because there
are rules
like you really did turn into Steve
Buscemi is it thank you I try it's the
line cuz it's both really nasally but
really he enunciates the word very much
so it's like anytime along but still has
kind of like that thick kind of city
accent but he enunciates really well too
so it's like it's a tough mix right
oh you're hitting out I left out some
valley girl okay there on the couch okay
this is the fridge go forth stalwart
hero okay okay yeah
[Music]
we don't really care thank y'all great
work on the shoe today sweetie but I'm
Joel oh I'm sorry I always get you two
mixed up
we don't care oh hey critic would you
next seed and when you walk off be sure
to sort of walk on that way so we can
still see you
[Music]
I'm okay
yeah I always feel like one more thing
is missing are trying to think I was
gonna say bow and arrow like we did with
Rachel Rachel was valley girl Legolas
get your big round glasses yep oh you
did it
whoa did you get him from good great
yeah
you fell right into wait what is this Oh
holding it let's see yeah just yeah yeah
that looks really funny okay perfectly
ridiculous like oh my god
valley girl boner Valley boner
there you hear me eight milk that makes
it so much
it's like I'm going to blow him up
oh love guess I can't fault your logic
okay you got that yeah the long devil
Barnett since it double born a phony
French totally French's french fries
okay ready I'll give you the lead in
line
wow he sure is acting strange it's neat
devil boner Oh totally strange damn a
boner you don't see what's gonna be as
he usually I I'm definitely a double
owner you wouldn't call me double boner
if I wasn't double boner right I think
it's a kick fault your logic there Chuck
good try and one more I'll settle with
him with a southern accent just replace
all the ers with a H's just yeah let me
demo better I if I wasn't a better think
you feel obviously have you seen the
date when Pele plays that really
high-maintenance woman it's like on Jack
I'm Jack just do it like that
that was a dying yeah he's sure it's
acting strange is any devil bone there
ah tallest ROG devil burger
you don't seem it's good happy as usual
oh I'm totally a double burner you won't
call me a double burner if you didn't
think I was double burner right
guess I can't fault your logic I'm at
cha yeah so stop loud and then just have
a big chop all right whatever you ready
chop chop just like that for safety
[Music]